alors un nouveau mouvement de
contestation prend forme à montréal des
personnes âgées autonomes qui conteste
l'imposition de nouvelles normes de
sécurité dans leur résidence
donc après les carrés rouges voici les
catégories jacques bissonnet où est ce
que je vis dans un mois c'est 1 bc
puisse fait son affaire madeleine
mauvais 74 ans ne veut pas que le
gouvernement se mêle de sa vie nous
sommes autonomes ne sommes pas des
vieillards qui ont besoin de toutes ces
choses là nous on n'a pas besoin de ça
et va nous obliger la nouvelle
certification impose des normes de
sécurité dans toute l'existence pour
personnes âgées autonomes ou en perte
d'autonomie
le gouvernement veut éviter la
répétition de drames comme celui ci de
l'île verte qui a fait 32 victimes de
nouvelles normes notamment sur la
surveillance 24 heures sur le nombre de
gicleurs sur l'eau chaude ou même sur
les dossiers médicaux
mais je me plais consolide tout un
mouvement de contestation prend forme
les caries guéri moins chaud au coeur on
essaie de musique antillaise il parce
que j'ai pas besoin de ça on n'est pas
satisfaits par le gouvernement moi je
suis je suis 13 est un objet possède une
infirmière médias de prendre ma vitamine
neige depuis ce matin ses résidents qui
habitent des coopératives d'habitation
comme celle ci dans le quartier ville
émard ont des moyens financiers limités
et craignent maintenant une augmentation
de leur loyer si le gouvernement nous
ajoute des indes et des services un ça
va augmenter énormément au loyer
deux options s'offrent à eux une
exception ou encore un assouplissement
des mesures pour les coopératives
d'habitation pour personnes âgées
autonomes ou encore une aide financière
spéciale pour permettre la mise en place
des nouvelles mesures de sécurité
issigeac bissonnet radio canada montréal